what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel back again
please eddie listen we're here to do
another review just let them know what
one you are our new recruiter yes i am
indeed so if you want to get on the show
boys and girls more girls um hit me up
who's ready to drop my dm and we'll
we'll decide on the day you can come in
and you can give your two pence on the
show like the video as you guys know the
most important metric for youtube is the
like button so if you can like the video
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell so you can every time
we're live so today this is about this
is almost a year ago now yes this is one
of my first interactions with crazy so
yeah it is you look it's a clock so at
first i didn't know that these type of
women existed
i grew up in the suburbs we all had
brothers to bully us slightly so i
didn't realize women were this
delusional why though who's your
brothers no i just i like most of my
friends like dated normal guys it's just
like didn't
i mean i'm sure they're you know above
average in some way but they weren't
like
was it and it wasn't like that i'll show
you yes all right according to free let
me see that sort of sort of space
back he's he's immediately like i'm
gonna let's celebrate like i want to
take you out and i'm like oh
how many how many dates have you guys
gone on one
okay yeah we went on one right before i
left that was our first first date
a date go ahead sorry so now we'll go i
guess on the second one
but he's kind of short he's only like
five nine
oh that's you're you're what like five
i'm five eight that's tall enough right
not really you know manifesting a tall
man one of the other guys i'm talking to
is six foot seven
oh wow
and we'll be going out soon it's just a
matter of like scheduling we just
haven't been able to like
link on the schedules we both work a lot
mm-hmm
there's another guy who i just made this
whole take a tick tock about who
was like all about me asking me out
calling me all these pet names my love
and all this [ __ ] and then we're talking
and i was like oh you have the vaccine
right and he was like no
i was like you're not vaccinated and you
want to go out with me i'm like i'm not
going out with you you're not vaccinated
what are you [ __ ] kissing you you're
not vaccinated i'm like
really oh i wouldn't care i don't care
in too many arenas where you have to be
vaccinated like i work at a yoga studio
where we're requiring proof of
vaccination that's where i am right now
holding all this laundry i own all these
music festivals where they're requiring
proof of vaccination and to me it's so
much deeper than just like do you or
don't you it's about that like i don't
want to have that debate with you right
like clearly
if we don't view it the same way we're
not in alignment
right how do we feel about her so far if
you date a girl like this and you don't
see the craziness it's your fault i
blame the guys who give her the the
false pretense that she's actually a cri
like a credible woman she sounds crazy
what what one minute 36 seconds in and i
wouldn't believe
wasting no time again like this he's mad
you see how much more patient i used to
be yeah yeah yeah because you were just
visiting like yeah i wouldn't care like
probably me only been like we talking
about that are you talking about i i
used to be a lot nicer
all right guys five nine you know one
six seven go away spinning plates and
all that
stuff
so would you not would you not date
someone that was different than you like
politically no i wouldn't what are what
are your standards like what are your
requirements for a guy
i feel like that's fair the political
one yeah because you you'd come to
clashes i guess it depends how open
minded you are to accept another of
abuse and how deeply you believe in your
political view so i understand if
someone wouldn't want to date someone
for it but i don't think it's it's a
door breaker either way that's the day
of liberal
[Laughter]
i might say they're concerned if you
don't like it
i hear liberal i'm like beta
vader
hey listen no no betas there's there's
listen i came from the liberal side and
i'm definitely not a beta so there's
some rosies
you think yeah
you think me yeah with a chest like mine
yeah
big man like me they are
impossible it had to be a little bit the
last time i was a bait i was 15 years
old yeah apparently at 22. no no no
of inconsistency yeah alpha only listen
yes i'll just call you alpha from now on
we're gonna fight what
okay alpha
i mean politically i definitely want us
to have the same view you know i'm a
black woman right so i'm not going to
date a white republican that would just
be a headache like why would we do that
to ourselves
okay we wouldn't travel in the same
circles and we don't view this the world
the same way so i want to use the world
the same as me and even if you're not
black but you're white and you like get
and understand the black struggle fine
but yeah i definitely want them to have
the same political views as me because
it's just
why bother and having those arguments
okay i'm just gonna turn into a fight
later
yeah no so what like what else
um well they have to have a car this
other guy who didn't have a vaccine he
didn't even have a car i was like how
are you coming to take me out you don't
have a car you know i'm not driving
anywhere yeah
so that's like minimum requirement you
have to have a car um i've also realized
that i want someone that has like some
sort of creative or like
job and entertainment like i have
um
you have to be very ambitious because i
am very ambitious i want to be able like
you know we'll spend our days or
whatever separately and then at the end
of the night i wanted to be able to come
together and talk about all the exciting
things that happened in each of our
lives right like okay this other guy was
like well i'm not rich i'm a regular guy
how does that sound to you as a man
i'm
repulsed i'm just thinking that the
level of entitlement to have these
requests so brazenly
on a platform it's like how does she get
to this conclusion to think that what
she's saying is is okay what was you
thinking at the time look at my face
yeah you just laughing okay then that
was all right i was like
because i kind of wanted to let her talk
and just see what she's doing
um she's about to dig herself a big hole
yeah but um no i thought she was dying i
pushed back later you'll see i hope so
nicely i hope so like i'm very polite
yeah
i'll forget to see weapons
okay
and i was like that's fine but like i'm
not a regular girl
i'm i'm not so like if you're if you are
going to date me like either you have to
be able to handle that or if i could do
it now i'd be like you look pretty
regular to me
honestly that was your time to just clap
back that's exactly what came into my
head i said who do you think you are
that baby girl you're clapped what's
going on and for your views you don't
know what's next i'm not clutching ugly
oh you'd say she's ugly she's one to ten
where'd you give it i'm giving her a
straight four and the reason being i
reckon if she'd not open her mouth she
might scrape at five 5.5 but now that
i've seen an attitude i don't want
nothing to do with this girl you see me
i'm running so far away so pass smash or
pass i'm pausing yourself also has to
not be like regular like i don't think
i'm like just an average person like
that to be boring
okay so
that's another thing i hate when a girl
says you have to handle me i don't get
that i i i really it despises me why
would that why do i need to handle you
as a man who is ambitious and seeking
out being on his own mission the last
thing i want to come home is to a woman
i have to handle like that what does
that make sense i need a man that can
handle me how do you for what and then
you want to be complaining about are we
fighting jonathan
is this a competition i hear alphas do
that
that's the thing the girls like that i
always end up with [ __ ] but yeah and
that doesn't doesn't last long because
they're not walking over the guy they
need a bit more authority in their life
and they end up stepping out on it on
the game doesn't make no sense so that
yeah all this handed in nonsense to me
is there like a do you care okay would
you be cool with a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah
okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
you wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring i'm getting an 8 carat
question cut vintage engagement ring if
you make 45 000 a year it would take
what
four years no eight years to afford how
much
i don't know anything about ranks how
much how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
ring has to sparkle from across the
street like you have to do that [ __ ]
it's good blind people well that's so
superficial that's like so superficial
but it's about so much more than that
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right i go to yoga with this girl
who's an eight-carat diamond engagement
ring yeah the weed company and drives an
audi
so it's about more than just it's about
the fact that you can afford that
okay well i'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because i'm telling
no but not not in a good way not in a
good way i'm telling you like my dad
would but if my mom asked for that from
my dad my dad would have told her to go
find a new boyfriend because there was
no way in hell he was going to spend 200
000 on an engagement ring and that's
something
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had 10 kids my
mom never
he said he's built to the becoming that
he wasn't that originally right
he wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think um this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like like to me that's
like such an unwise investment to spend
200k
diamonds appreciate it's not listening
why don't you want to ask me like i know
the guys all of my brothers that are
older than me make six figures like
that's very common in my family i you
don't you don't want to ask me what i'm
just curious as to how does she come to
the conclusion that she's even worth
that amount of investment because that's
how that's what it is an investment if
i'm going to spend money in a girl like
that i'm invested in my future that that
is a bad investment that is a liability
that's not an asset to your life so i
want to understand how she's come to the
point where she thinks i'm worth the
200k ring oh this girl my yoga class
what i'm rich i wish i could remember
the girl at her yoga class she sent me
her instagram after the stream oh really
she was hotter
i'm sorry but hot [ __ ] get privileged
like i don't i don't know what to tell
you not everyone [ __ ] was created equal
no it's big facts but in even some of
the the top echelon of women don't get
200k engagement i know so you that i'm
rating a four
if you're gonna get 200k ring you're
super you're lucky if you get a tattoo
she gets tiring so base listen when i've
got enough money to get a little
something else now this woman yeah she's
she's special oh my god no no
oh my god no
that's like i would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know really yeah like i don't
know for me like i told you like my my
status is going up like i just did a
music festival where i made 30 grand
over there in one weekend you know what
i mean like i need somebody who can be
on that level
right but the problem is like guys don't
care about your money
right there
i i know but it doesn't like you know
like
i'm just i think you're going to miss
out on a lot of guys with like this like
to me these are like crazy high
standards so
today i listened to my dating coach
she said you do not get your expectation
you get your minimum standard
who is your dating coach married yes and
she has a baby and her wedding ring is
at least five carats who is your dating
coach fire that woman
fire that woman what kind of nonsense is
that i know where they get it from it's
the same place that girl got it from and
on your show which one the the andrea
yes yes
[ __ ] yeah that's the book and it's
like basically the whole idea of the
book is like you you raise your
standards right make him wait longer
it's like steve harvey tells me
i understand the concept but it's like
in practice doesn't work no because it's
like you're selling a used product for
more hump like humble yourself and they
always come off as so it's like the same
attitude like they come off so arrogant
because they're like being told they're
the prize but i'm like are you it's a
very idealistic perspective because it's
just it's nice to think positive
affirmations are gonna work for you but
unless you're the thing that's worthy of
what is trying to work towards the two
don't meet well like 16 year olds 18
year olds that that would maybe work for
because you're you're a virgin then yeah
but like but even in it again does it
make sense what did you say you have to
work to your minimum standard whatever
oh oh what sorry i meant like that book
i'm not this is crazy this is this is
crazy this wouldn't work for any no
yeah don't don't confuse that this is
not this would not work for anybody
the idea that i'm assuming she's an
older woman because she looks like an
older woman how old do you think she is
she's touching she's mid-thirties no she
says you'll see yeah
so because if she's if she's the age i
think she is her values really
depreciate
by a stupid amount then her attitude's
disgusting then she's trying to say oh
you know i made 30 30k and i don't who
cares about that stuff if you came to
talk to me about that stuff i'll get
bored and keep it moving no that's what
i think that's so rude like i feel like
you should not throw money in faces yeah
like you shouldn't tell people how much
you make like that's rude
that's so disrespectful like it's one
thing like if people are like i'm like
ma'am i didn't ask
and and i don't believe you like i could
say i'm the president it doesn't mean
it's not it doesn't mean it's real but i
think this is something that girls do
in terms of how they've started to adopt
some of the masculine traits and trying
to stun and flaunt what they have with
to men assuming that men think like them
in the sense that if you tell me how
much money you're making it's supposed
to shock me around me or get me excited
but for most men i'm seeing masculine
traits so i'm saying you're not the type
of woman i want to be because we're
almost going to be in competition with
each other and i don't think that's
healthy for a relationship
so
what if she's doing it nothing here
she's done is correct from a date and
whoever a coach is they need to they
they need to
string put her name out there so no one
can use it because she's just talking
about she's center to me but like she's
just getting her on the show i know i
tried i invited her i thought of the
scenes yes
but no she wouldn't she wouldn't come on
yeah for obvious reasons i don't know
why i was a lot nicer but yeah and her
man is rich excuse me okay you know he
herself makes like 30 to 50 grand a
month coaching women in love
i mean good luck if that like works for
you i just like to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like i think like
guys are gonna hear that and be like no
no no you have to have the man who's
okay with maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance even her
smile is put me up she's in here
well she's like mentally 14. yeah like
that sounds like some girls just don't
grow up no
it's like you feel like you're talking
to a child is that accountability
element no one's ever made her
accountable for actions so she's
probably gone through life just thinking
if she does this makes sense but she
needs a dating coach for that for one to
show that she needs support in one
sector it's even it's like even on these
shows like it's so hard to talk to girl
i've been convinced women shouldn't vote
because when i talk to girls it's like
there's enough empirical evidence there
to suggest that
i'll say 10 times please don't bring up
an exception to the rule but that's what
they know
oh but what about this thing it happens
once out of a hundred times what if what
if this horror story happens what if he
like just wait it comes it's gonna get
worse but if you are dating a man that
is okay with maintaining you you're fine
you're not high maintenance then you're
just on their level
okay but i'm just thinking like
like
i i know but those guys that are making
like
like that amount of money like
like i think they typically want like
the young like 21 22 year olds
i don't think so
what
i'm 30. so i'm not that old i'm actually
no i don't age to be wiped up by
somebody who's like in their 40s and
like
i love watching your eyes
because i'm carefully watching her body
language to her mannerisms because as
soon as you drop that you can see that
she'd realize you know what you're
speaking facts but then her defensive
side came no no i don't think so when in
reality she knows that oh [ __ ] maybe
they do
right well yeah i was like her responses
are freaking hilarious ready to be
serious and start popping out babies a
twenty one year old electric
your eyes like popped out of your head
unless you're kylie jenner is
realistically too young to be like
popping out kids
like you're too young
it sounds like i would date a 45 year
old i seriously would and so it's like
you're going to compete with like me
good luck like girls like
[Music]
it's an easy choice
leave a leave it in the comments
and i'm just saying like like you're
going to compete with like girls my age
no it's not even just me it's just like
ah but even though she says she's 30 i
thought she was older than that yeah so
that really depreciates the value i've
said it before like you can't compete in
this market and the things you want are
just stupid it's stupid because girls
half her age would well not look at half
age girls like younger than her don't
want those things so you're not even
worth that like that you don't have that
sort of value you ask for those things
it's crazy this is this way it's like
it's even better yeah i mean that's just
i'm sorry the 200 000 like that's crazy
to me
that's like
oh my gosh i cannot believe that's
crazy being someone that can make that
amount of money in a shorter period of
time like somebody who would say a
musical artist right a musical producer
somebody who's in entertainment somebody
who's on a tv show somebody who
does like concerts and tours that amount
of money
isn't
the same
to them you know what i mean
what do you what do you mean
like say i was dating somebody like a g
eazy right okay he makes 150 000 minimum
per show minimal that's what he makes in
a show yeah so if he does a couple shows
the 200 grand to him he won't even feel
it
no but like this is something coming she
easy jaden haisley
how can't you put that g easy i will be
yeah she's
[Music]
you know how hot that girl is my girl's
stunning
this girl lacks any form of
self-reflection perception
i wonder who her friends are like what
did he not talk about there's just zero
substance here i met her once in l.a her
friends i don't know i didn't really
meet her friends i just saw them in the
past because she actually sounds like a
little girl i know they're like 13th
mental he sounds like a little girl yes
is she's 30 years old it's a big woman
you know i think that's a lot of my show
i'm like how are these people older than
me not like you're a big one this is the
level of cognitive function that you
have to be ashamed of yourself
this is something coming from someone
like i've been in a relationship with a
guy that was worth over a million
like i but i would never in a million
years ask him to spend 200k on a rank
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like i'm not entitled to
his money
i mean
and that's why he deserves here's the
thing if i can afford it myself
i will i would want you to be able to
get it for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah i guess like we kind of probably
have different like views on like
spending habits because to me i'm like i
would question
i don't know if this she asked this late
well or you asked it later in the in the
show but um do you think she'd accept
getting cheated on she would she would i
didn't ask her this but i asked her in a
different okay reaction we did fair
enough fair enough because like she's
quoting people in the entertainment
industry you were notorious for just
yeah no she said she said she'd accept
cheating
but i like i don't even think that's
enough because i just don't like
entitled like i i would never ask
someone to spend that amount of money on
me i hope that's how you even how would
you even ask that
like how like she does
like i would i would never expect
something like that like i like i don't
know i'm just never because i see the
thing that the precipice of stupidity as
a man is to be used in that type of
level because that's just again we're
talking about simpson betas that's the
most simple thing to ever do like a
woman request a 200k ring just go out
there and buy it for her you're you're
an absolute wasteman by the same time
there must be guys who do that for her
to have the perception of that no she's
never had a boyfriend
no
no i'm serious that's it yeah she's
she's lost it yeah i you
you're done
you benito'd you're done
yo it's what american girls are like i'm
staying in the uk
no i have experienced uk girls the last
couple of months you don't get
no they are equal
do you keep your girls over there
boy you
you know damn well what's coming to this
living room you know damn well
oh boy stay tuned for more
anyways we we live stream on um tuesday
wednesday thursday saturday tune in tune
in
tune in
even if i had the money i would never
spend that on a ring
but i'm also not that much of a jewelry
person right so it's like you're not
gonna need to be buying me diamonds for
every anniversary or
jewelry all the time like get me my ring
i would hope if someone spent two
hundred thousand dollars on an
engagement ring that you would never
need a gift again at the very least be a
jewelry person
how do you go from i wanna i want a ring
on my finger that's worth a house
yeah i'm not gonna value that house
because i'm not i don't really like
houses
you like this is a different level of
delivery you can't make this [ __ ] up you
can't make this [ __ ] up like you can't
what's wrong with people i don't know
chat to your people this is your people
look at this this is your gang i didn't
this was a random day i just went live
on ig
i wasn't expecting her to come like
this is is this your this is your echo
chamber this is your echo chamber
what are you doing with these people oh
my god you're right it's all me i just
teach her to be delusional
hell okay like honestly i'm alpha i'm
lead
i can see why you started your show now
i think this was a a pivotal moment in
your life where you thought you know
what i got to separate myself from this
this is the beginning this is this
and that's it i don't really need much
else
oh gosh sorry
oh hi nikki i just added you to it
no i have to like connect it to the
thing hold on
i've done like a youtube live with her
she's alright
oh
well in a minute sorry
i can i can drop you if this is a bad
time i just thought i'd add you to the
chat
no just real quickly because we got
dinner and lamb and all this other good
stuff she doesn't even look like she's
in shape
what she doesn't look like she's in the
shade people like she's
her condition
yeah she doesn't look like she's in the
vegetable
so again you just ask her a lot listen
this i love this live this is hilarious
this i love you but the girl's asking
for 300k diamond rings and everything on
this one
oh wait i have a question i have a
question go on if a guy
marries a single mom yep and then he she
has six more kids for him is he a simp
the guy is a single mom no
no because she had six more kids six
kids room okay are they still together
off the resort yeah yeah no no no he's
he's claimed that he's claiming that
that's a mini football team of subs
he's claimed that she ain't got no way
after that these guys are now saying
that women hit the wall at age 20. and
you're talking about the 200 000 they'll
be like oh god
but you guys are both women they're both
women so you really don't know
like how would you know but like being
around is being just like a lot of these
men they seem like they're in la la land
themselves
and it's like the people that they're
talking about is like who are you
meeting so as
two people are coming with completely
different expectations and like when you
were saying earlier you have pointed out
the person that was in the yoga class
she had a three hundred thousand dollar
ring the person your coach she has a
three hundred thousand dollar ring it
wasn't like base the reason the ring
that i have i wanted it because of the
fact that growing up
some there's no certain type of thing in
my family that that's what it was but it
wasn't because any of my friends had
that ring i couldn't care less what they
had so no i don't want it because they
have it i know i can have it because
they have it do you understand what i'm
saying like i understand that oh
having a hundred thousand dollar to two
hundred thousand dollar eight carat
diamond engagement ring is within my
grasp because i've seen it in real life
brett they're hotter than you
like i'm sorry i know i can have it
because they have it i i see the two
girls that she was talking about she
showed one i'd give an eight one i'd
give an adjustable six
what would you give her uh five four
and she's overweight four now that i've
seen her size i'm dropping it down to a
3.5
because her bod listen
i'm never going to be politically
creative but it's atrocious for a girl
that demands that much at the age of 30
you are a diminishing asset
like nothing about her
is is is worth
any form of
commitment mentally physically
spiritually
it's all zeros i'm 3.5 generous at this
point
i've seen a walkway from the camera i'm
seeing the fact come out this thing i
would even look to i wouldn't see girls
like this are invisible to me i wouldn't
even notice her normal day yeah
you're not wrong you're not
no no no no
she still thinks she's better than you
because you wouldn't buy it two hundred
thousand dollars that's what they girls
like this do though guys that reject
them they'll be like well i rejected him
because he ate blah blah blah like
that's how they are one film noticed is
all yeah her friends must be gassing her
up girls gassed each other up yeah girls
must be because they're not going to
tell you the reality it's learned like a
lot of the stuff i do on my show it's
learned it's not natural yeah
it's for women like we're a lot more get
along you know yeah yeah yeah
i think i think that means they're
gassing her up and one thing i found i
noticed this in college attractive girls
would choose less attractive girls to
bring attention more attention to them
yeah but then she ends up adopting the
the characteristics of the attractive
girls and this is the result of
the adoption of those attitudes
and there's this very unrealistic
standard she's going to be very sad
she's going to fit into that demographic
of successful career women who's 45 and
single
with uh with no kids yeah that is she's
heading right for that one she's not
even
my feeling is that she isn't good with
money so she'll be broke too okay
imagine like i just just my feeling yeah
i associate with people who have these
things they're in my circles of people
they're in my friend groups
and i know i can have it because i've
seen it not it's not that i want it
because they have it i want it and then
i've seen it i've seen validation of it
in my in front of my face
well i'm not saying that you you
shouldn't want it because i do know
people that they've dreamt about a
certain type of specific wedding since
they were children i on the other hand i
couldn't kill us
so there was i i definitely understand
that and especially when it does come
time for people to get married where
people like oh why would you spend this
money why i'm like i don't care that's
that person's prerogative that's what
they want that's what they want so if
you're saying you see that because of
the fact that you see it on the everyday
person that you communicate with so you
knowing that it's something that's
accessible so if that's that thought
process
okay but i don't know
i'm just saying like i think you're
looking for like a one percent guy which
is very rare and i think you're gonna
like
like you're gonna overlook a lot of guys
that literally make that amount of money
would like have that money to spend but
choose not to because their values are
to save money
like that's what i'm saying like you
would overlook like my dad in this
situation who's like
top half a percent but your dad is
getting your mom to pop out ten kids and
this is the thing i grew up in that
family i i know a lot of people with a
lot of money i don't know a single
person with a 200k engagement ring or a
wedding ring i don't know one mm-hmm
like because
it's it's
a waste of money it's a depreciating
asset in that sense the diamonds
appreciate it
i think she was talking about itself and
she said that the nonsense unfortunately
by herself but now she's she's tapped do
you know what if you were trying to buy
diamonds too by himself fair enough
you're gonna hold on to that diamond and
you don't even have jewelry anyway so
probably we couldn't wear it anyway
so
yeah yeah i think take it from you rich
people in rich circles don't spend
nothing like that money like that but at
the same time that's why she wanted
someone in the entertainment industry
she doesn't want a guy who's like a
businessman who's savvy with money she
wants someone that's equally as stupid
you know it's crazy so in the social
media circles there's a lot of people
that claim to have money
i could tell who actually has it and who
does it also and i'm always right every
person that i've said they don't they're
not a million like i'm not saying they
don't do well but like they'll claim to
be like a millionaire or something and
i'm like no they're not i can tell why
millionaires want to keep it a secret
and like they just it's just they move
different like they're not trying to get
the flashy watches they're not trying
there's a certain level like
billionaires i can't tell you [ __ ] about
i don't know billionaires like they're
they're different you know level of
ranch or like like two like i don't know
250 plus millionaires like that's that's
a different like
yeah but like i don't know i could just
tell by the way people move because i
grew up around a lot of people but it
wasn't like like there's different types
there's like the millionaires that are
like they call them men of value and
those are the people that kind of like
get their money tell everyone to [ __ ]
off build their business and like don't
deal with people and then there's the
millionaires that are like
in the like fast
life and the fast scenes and stuff but
like
but but number two a lot of them are
faking it yeah i believe to be true
because when i think about people that i
went to school with
like they're not
thousands they don't have thousands
literally just the average person
who
will go to dubai chill the fancy cars
and present themselves as libertas a
particular standard of life that isn't
consistent with the reality people with
money can see through it exactly so if
if they can do that then again when you
reach the higher levels even with
rappers a lot of rappers again fake it
till you make it you know they rent the
chains they rent the cars
and then present it as reality but
it's not
yeah i completely agree with that stuff
who's like
top half a percent but your dad also up
getting your mom to pop out ten kids i'm
not trying to pop out
because my daughter she's like yeah but
your mom top popped out ten kids i'm
like so you also don't have children to
offer him so he gets even less but
that's what i was going to say is crazy
because if i'm going to put that amount
of money in your finger again this is an
investment
and i want my legacy to be here you
better believe you're popping out my
legacy don't ever listen i'm not giving
you that kind of mullah for you to just
sit at home and try and be pretty you're
living free
[Laughter]
you don't make no
it's at home doing nothing you're just a
waste of space nah you better be ready
for kids at least
bare minimum
how many kids how many kids is worth a
200k right none not with her
that's the
say she's hot how many kids is worth a
200k ring
and you get to cheat and i get to cheat
yeah i'll say i'll give it five
five five
yeah and i can step out yeah five five
kids yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're buying the two 200k ring i'm
putting your finger on five years so it
i didn't even know i thought most guys
won't talk like over six foot
so then when the you know different
people were sharing oh well this is the
percent of these type of i didn't even
know that was the thing because i'm like
most guys i know pretty tall
now you're adding the height to two
hundred thousand dollar ring plus
i don't know girl
i know what the universe knows
well at least your options are open
you're not just trying to just outside
of the hype you're open to dating you
know every not everyone i was just
talking to this guy who doesn't even
have a headboard he has a bed and one
pillow and i said where's your headboard
she's the kind of girl
yeah that talks about astronomy
i was just thinking about zodiac signs
the universe is going to give it to me
nah stop it stop it you're going to
she's the type of girl to tell you that
we don't match because you're a leo and
i'm a diss and no
this girl's tats
the women that believe in zodiac zodiac
signs have higher levels of narcissism
i can uh listen i think that's legit
especially when it comes to the
westernized version of the zodiac signs
because that is just a money-making
movement believe in zodiac signs do you
know what oh no no no no no because i
did it we did an episode of a girl um
and she was a
vedic i think they called it vedic it's
the indian version and that's quite deep
it goes quite deep and some of it
does present itself as scientific i i
can't i can't validate none of it but it
sounds legit
compared to the to the western version
listen i know you didn't i don't see you
no they don't see
but i think the indian it's more of a
religion
that i can see
that it's more real than the western
version
arguably
but i don't follow this stuff myself
he goes oh i'm just a regular guy i said
oh
i didn't say i don't want to talk to you
anymore i said okay
okay so okay so
how do you know
i was literally thinking you're getting
your black blown out by a guy with no
headboard a guy with just a mattress
respect yourself woman yeah do not say a
word how tall is he
how tall is he
i'm saying he's he's he's five six tony
my brothers didn't have had boards for
years
yeah college in a time where you know
you're meant to be broke but she's 30
years old yeah i know so she banging
guys in college now as well did i
misunderstand you're okay with like not
getting that stuff
like i i just thought like i thought you
said you need the 200k like would you
marry that guy
well i mean this is also the same guy
that doesn't have the vaccine so i
wouldn't even go out with him but
um
no here's the thing like the way i see
it in my head is that like by the time i
get there we will be in the place
to afford
those things and like also you guys like
i the circles that i run in the people
that i know like i meet very influential
people who can afford those things all
the time my everyday life i mean pearl
you saw my apartment like you saw where
i live you know what i mean like i live
in a luxury building where you have to
make at least 100 dollars a year just to
afford to live in the place where i live
see if i
if i had to do this again i would have
said then why aren't they dating you
mm-hmm you're in the right rooms
you're around the right people and you
seem to be the
the one left out because you're quoting
your friends your friends were married
so i'm saying but what i've noticed
about her
she's a sheep she just conforms to the
standard of the room she proceeds she's
in
everything she's saying
nothing's actually come from her it's
what she sees other people doing which
sets her standard for what she should be
doing
she's just a sheep she's just around hot
girls i think she can ask for the things
they can ask for
right but i'm saying like to a guy like
money is nothing like men do not care
about your money yes you did phil
this wins
that's the first time i met her it was
the first time
we did a video together
yeah
yeah
i'm disappointed in you i've met her
twice disappointed in you i was oh my
god i was in la for like a couple months
if this is your roots
i'm glad and she was another tick-tocker
this was when i was on take talk before
i even did youtube we just met up to do
a tank top
all right now you know what
whatever whatever beta
so if money is nothing they can afford
my 200 000 engagement ring
no that's that's not what i mean i mean
like money money money gives you no
value so like i'm not more attractive to
a guy because i make more money like if
anything like they don't prefer it
because they like would prefer someone
with more free time to hang out with
them and like
i'm gonna make a video about that i
think it's actually ba
you think that's bs
yes
i rece after seeing the whole thing you
know the podcast that you were on
and seeing that whole drop i'm sorry
about that you think but this is
something else
now that a lot of guys are saying that
they want traditional women traditional
women traditional women and then they
don't value the money and other stuff
i've now come up with a theory that the
only reason why they want these
traditional women that do not have money
is so that they can have the ability to
leave these women at will and have them
destitute because especially now with
the whole texas band of the laws and
stuff and seeing these guys are just
like cheering thank god we can have you
barefoot and pregnant back in the
kitchen and not working anymore
i at first i thought that that money
thing didn't really matter but i'm
starting to realize no these guys just
want the ability to leave you high and
dry and then laugh in your face
girl i got
ain't nobody getting pregnant or having
any unwanted babies
a thousand dollars people have to do
something
what kind of radical feminism is she
listening to i don't know
the divorce statistics are well
documented worldwide
there is nothing to support anything
she's saying she even used the word like
destitute she wouldn't leave his
dirt broke
she's here she's she's tapped
women are the ones leaving men i know
many the ones leaving and and the facts
are there
that's the evil discussion worth having
so whatever i want to see
how sound this theory is hopefully she's
finished it
because that's a that's nonsensical i
thought my keys crossed my eyes dotted
like my own little uh um what do you
call it new thing that i'm just like
what they really want i don't i don't
think so like because i don't i don't
think so i think like
like
like money just isn't like attractive to
them like they just don't like like when
we see an ambitious like driven man that
turns us on that does not turn a guy on
to like like i think they don't want
like a girl that's like bad with money i
think that's like a turn off i think
that like they don't want a girl that's
like
you know doesn't like is terrible
finances whatever but like i just don't
see guys like
being like oh my gosh that's so sexy
she's the ceo like the same way girls
are
like dad
ambition
i said the men that date me are
attracted to my ambition
i would have agreed with you paul until
watching that podcast that you were on
and all these women that they're pushing
these traditional values on that could
barely even formulate a
complete sentence and that's why i
wanted to do the reaction with you on
there because these other girls who are
normally on there and they're like
pushing the whole thing that we don't
care about this we don't care about that
meanwhile these are just only fan girls
that you're trying to push these type of
values on i'm like this whole thing
makes no sense
well well that's the problem with fresh
and fit is they just bring on like the
trashiest girl and i said that on the
podcast i was like do you guys think
you're in like a little bit of a bubble
like
but i think that doesn't they see women
as though i don't think they see women
as like
actual functional human beings
okay
hello
hi
he was on earlier he said he wanted to
come back on
um
i
i totally just like
the point of
um
one again back to homegirl
she keeps talking like she's already
engaged in due to be married
guys that date her
love her ambition
yeah none of these guys are staying
around
and two
this idea or this notion that she's
trying to or this narrative she's trying
to push her that
men
somehow
want to just use women who don't see
them as humans
i think that goes back to what this this
misogynist idea of of pushing this idea
that women are misogynistic
it's not true
we don't like your money it's what it is
when a woman is going to be there be our
peace support us and have time for us
that's what we're asking for we don't
want it's not it's not rocket science
men are very simple we want the bus nuts
and have peace
if you can do that
we're happy
i'm saying
no they
oh my gosh she's talking about they're
going to be high and dry in the kitchen
i'm like
[ __ ] nonsense it's like
what men do you know
truly don't know she i don't think she's
hearing this from men i think she's
hearing this from women oh [ __ ] because
men wouldn't say stuff like this but
literally
they're
what was it men
women
um
are thinking that men
uh want women that um earn like a lot of
money or more money than
that's just simply not true you're hard
you're kind of low so can you say that
again
like more
yeah
i said
i said um men don't men don't value
women that make a lot of money that's
it's not really a turn on for us guys so
how much money do you make sir
got it
oh gosh
hello how much money oh you're back
okay
maybe it's maybe it's my device
let me switch on to a different device
do you know what
she was being
she's very abrasive
she was being quite nice talking to you
i could see
a feminine essence when she was talking
to you girls
but as soon as she couldn't hear him
she was very abrasive in the way she hey
i can't hear you like
she was her decorum was way better and
now she's literally just like yeah
i can see why she doesn't do good with
men and again men with higher sh no i
can see why she [ __ ] guys who wanted a
headboard
because they're the only men they're
going to part with that [ __ ] you see
a high status man the men that she wants
will never take that kind of talk even
as many schools that is i wouldn't put
that that rubbed me the wrong way
well i'm like why are you asking him how
much he makes that's rude outright i
don't know the guy from nowhere they
know his name
that's so rude like i just
i just think it's like
that's
i've like told people this like you
shouldn't really talk about how much
money you make but the ego we're not
like
we're having a conversation here i'm
talking to you as a man from my
perspective in regards to the matter at
hand
well how much money do you make sir
like is his experience less valid
because like i could say how much do you
weigh taylor like
but
she's placed herself above him
yeah in in her demeanor the way she
speaks like she's asserting herself
above him that again for what reason who
do you think you are and what is it that
you're trying to achieve by
doing this
she's not a two
too
generous
should i make the man run away
[Music]
no i think
men that make like 50 000 a year are
going to be the ones that say oh we
don't care about how much money the
woman makes
i think he was talking about my theory
about um i don't believe that because i
just think that they want to be able to
be the bread runners to leave these
women destined to and begging because
after the whole thing um only fancy 50
000 isn't even bad decent money yeah
for that kind of money that's like
pretty good in some areas to be honest
like it depends where you live but like
that's pretty good and like you're going
to nebraska just like
yeah for most but even in the uk the
equivalent what that probably like 45
50k yeah that's delicious you're living
good yeah you're living good like you
could afford to live in london with that
yeah so yeah i have to say that crazy
all she does is sell glitter too really
she thinks she's a g
i could definitely see that um
the men love [ __ ]
vibe coming from her now you'll see it
i'm telling you once you realize like
the attitude like you're not gonna be
able to unsee it it's like all the girls
that have read this book
have this like i want to read the book
actually i've been recommended it a few
times uh yeah i
i've read it a couple times oh yeah yeah
i can tell
doesn't mean i agree with it whatever
whatever
you can say i'm the i'm the biggest
[ __ ]
bitching
like i love how i try to flip it it's
reclaiming that
so many guys are so excited i can't wait
till these women fail and then they you
know they're just completely out and
homeless and begging for people to
change outside like
jesus
calm down well no i think it's not that
i think like people don't enjoy like
seeing people cheat and win
so like in this example like these girls
are kind of cheating right they don't
really have any real skills they're just
like hot
sell their body on the internet and then
they get
that hotness right
what
these girls they have to maintain that
hotness you work out these girls no
easy like skinny and pretty but other
ones like they have to work out they
have to do like
you know a lot more than i have to do to
be able to take their clothes off on the
internet and have people want to look at
them
yeah
30k a month could could you find the
motivation to like take like
not eat as much like that's what i'm
going to do 30k a month not having to be
in the gym so i don't know
i said i could make that in a month not
having to be in a gym well i know but
we're not talking about you we're
talking about the only fans girls like
that's that's the topic like i think men
like are happy with their downfall
because you're watching these girls
literally
like
fat [ __ ] because literally he's not
talking nonsense
essentially when because a guy could
never do that so like when they say like
oh like they're in the streets whatever
like i mean usually like it's a certain
type of guy that's going to like go out
of his way and comment that but i'm
saying like it's i would guess it's
because we're essentially watching them
cheat it's like a comment oh god i'm so
tired of these
this is a tactic girls do all the time
we'll say something
and when the shoe fits they'll be like
well i don't do that and i'm like well
i'm not talking about you
i'm not talking about you
yeah
you definitely had more patience back
then i would have i would have flipped
out banner and i would have told her
about herself
110 percent i had a lot more patience
i'm going on vacation tomorrow guys
i need it i'm so tired
we're saying that it's the same reason
why they would turn around and tell me
that i can't complain because of not
having a certain type of privilege and
someone's going to have a upper hand at
anything
so then if we can then turn around and
say oh well you can't cry because you're
not societies whatever and you're not
this well then you can't cry because
you're a man and that woman got a
restaurant in the bbl okay i know but
we're not talking about like we're like
the whole point was we're saying like
why do these guys
like prelim are they excited for these
girls downfall like you know these girls
have to work at subway after only fans
closes i'm saying it's because we're
watching them essentially cheat
um i don't think it's because men want
to be the breadwinners or anything like
that i think like these guys are
irritated that girls can just take off
their clothes and have an easy life
but these are still the same men that
are saying that life isn't fair for any
other woman that complains about oh well
i don't look at this and i don't look
like that they'll turn around and say
well it's not my fault you're average
looking it's not my fault that you're a
different third and you have to suck it
up and say you know what you're right
what what do you mean i don't i don't
understand what you're saying
in regards to like these are the same
guys that are saying that these women
cheated yes they did the breast
augmentations and the bbl's to be able
to get them i don't think
but then don't
but those guys also attention typically
not like relationship attention
but they're still getting the money but
the only also with that i can't then
turn around and say oh it's not fair
because i don't have blonde hair or i
don't have this feature and it doesn't
make me quit and then they'll turn
around and say okay well that's your
business
it's so hard to get girls to just stay
on topic yeah that's not what we're
talking about
all right i was cause that's why i'm
glad you asked louise because i was
thinking where's she trying to go with
this
but she's again
i thought she came with a bit more sense
but she's got no sense evil
no okay this is i was
i never understood one time my
ex-boyfriend
said to me he told me right he's like
shut up i don't care
like like i was talking he's like shut
up like i don't like stop talking and i
thought it was so rude at the time
now i feel for you
i
because we just talked to talk a whole
lot of nothing you'll ask question a
they'll answer questions bcded but not
question a
it's it's actually quite a smart tactic
for someone who's not conscious enough
to understand what's being done
because
more time
she's gonna go off topic you'll forget
the main topic at hand and then follow
her topic
so she's led you astray
so if you're not noticing if you're not
savvy to these type of conversation
tactics then
they do work
that doesn't mean society and everyone
needs to see you as a preference so it's
the same way it's just like okay someone
has a
fair advantage over something so it's
like well okay the same way i have to be
okay with things the same way i don't
think i agree that's why i don't i don't
care what the only fans models doing all
i'm saying is like i don't think it's
these men thinking hmm i want to be the
breadwinner i hope only fans models go
to subway like i don't i don't think
that's what it is
yeah to me that doesn't make any sense
um sorry what were you gonna you said
you wanted to come on oh you're talking
about money right
yeah
yeah essentially like yeah guys guys
really don't care about um women's like
money i mean it can be an asset but
i mean
generally speaking like
when um
if a guy like
does care about women's money it's it's
typically because
they don't they make little to no money
so it's like
if she's making more than him then he's
essentially
um
it that essentially is going to
be an attractive attraction to him i'm
sorry i'm like super nervous
so if
if a woman is is wanting a guy that you
know
makes more than than her and she's
making a lot of money like say she's
like in the top
15 there's such thing as a girl that's
too broke to date
no
no no if she's attractive enough then
you'll help her get to a comfortable
place where she can prosper and you can
carry doing your thing no such thing
some guys say well you guys don't really
have college debt like that here of
course we do
i thought it was free no
when you say college from like
university yeah no it's not free i
thought it was free for uk people i paid
nine grand a year oh [ __ ] yeah it's oh
wow
because i've had some guys say they
won't date a girl with a certain amount
of college debt
like seriously
in the u.s
i understand it
i think in the uk the college debt is
she had 100k a debt
but how much is that actually paying of
like
if she when she's working she makes
average salary 100k that i understand
that
but then
how do you understand 100k 100k how do
you spend 100k that you don't have no i
understand that like but when you say
two broke today i'm i'm coming from the
perspective that she's brokers in like
she's not making a lot of money yeah
you know what i could probably take that
on if she had the right type of
character
intelligent caucus and all that kind of
stuff then i understand you're trying to
achieve something if you're like
but if you're just there for banner
which a lot of people went to college
for just there to drink and have fun
rack up your cv
body count yep um then uh i think yeah
because in the usa i think it works
differently in the uk
um
your university debt is only
a small portion of what you make that's
why it takes so long for us to pay off
so i think usually the average age is
about 50 60 to finish paying it off
but they take such an insignificant
amount out that you don't really notice
it um
so
there's a personal contact not us yeah
you guys is full-blown that you better
pay us back over repossessing [ __ ]
that's what seventy five thousand
dollars a year
um not
that's that's a small percentage that's
like not not not that many guys i don't
even make that i wish i made that
i have that effect again it's like
and typically when you find guys like
that they they typically want something
they
they they pretty much want
um they typically
i don't want to say they don't go after
the average looking women but they tend
to expect a lot out of a woman so
well
that's what i want to know i agree
because like what what is your money to
a guy that has money like it's nothing
i don't know i'm funny i'm going to
correlate this into a theory video and
it's going to be like because even like
he was just saying about oh if the guy
makes a certain type of money he could
not get access to a dirty pack of
looking woman well most of the time if
you're looking on youtube these guys are
getting access to again women they
cannot even formulate a complete
sentence
but that's not
that's not necessarily true if we look
at like the top um
like the billionaires right like a lot
of those like even let's take like
donald trump billionaire right melania
trump like that woman speaks three
languages she was a model right but like
she definitely could articulate more
than a sentence
i would have said more modern guys those
are the guys that clearly have been
around the block and no common sense
wise you do need someone that can
actually talk about different forms and
societies and stuff
right those are
those are the older gentlemen that
actually have been around and know what
how you move around circles these newer
guys like again it's just the idea of
i and then most of the time they're
taking they're moving the goal post
one minute you're saying that this is a
valuable person and the next minute is
someone else
she's just trying to find an argument
somewhere i need to be right she's just
trying to she's trying to
throw mother the one and see what sticks
and then hopefully someone says oh yeah
i know you're talking about no you're
just talking nonsense babe
just talking for talking sick i'm gonna
formulate a theriano
i've never understood but man is so much
better after doing this show like before
i was like
the girls can't be this bad
that's what we part with now you can see
where you have zero patience
i
i get it i get it so what what guys are
you talking about are you talking about
like fresh and fit
not just them but just guys that kind of
like circulates around those type of um
those group of men and even with the
idea of money i don't even understand if
we're talking about that concept because
if you're not even getting married to
the person why would you even care who
makes what money
um that is that is a valid are you
talking about like girls
no as well sorry i went back to the
point that we were making early about um
the theory that i was talking about um
if they wanted to leave women to be
destitute if they're not making this
have money but then the gentleman was
just being the guys don't care about
money and then i was pointing out why
are we talking about money if you're not
even marrying the person
well i think like like and you can
correct me as i'm wrong if i'm wrong as
a guy but like i don't think a guy minds
if a girl makes a lot of money i just
don't that's like just
do you want to say
this video is proof that men are dogs
what do you mean because
we you can see how repulsive by these
women yeah but there's man in there
still gonna hear this
be as repulsed as i am and still give
them a bit of wood and still give them
the woody have you ever smashed a girl
that repulsed you yes
and i went church after
i went to repent for my sins so
so you're one of the guys i was i was a
dog but i practiced discipline and i say
this to all men men have to practice
discipline to prevent themselves from
falling into traps where they end up
sleeping women like this accidentally
getting them pregnant and then messing
up your whole life men need to practice
discipline because guys like this don't
deserve they don't reserve the wood
until they they come to a level where
they deserve the wood okay see we gotta
earn wood you gotta earn the wood oh
okay when you're when you think like
that you got underwood but obviously the
fortunate thing for women is that you're
born of value yeah you're born in a
place where you're you're gonna be
hunted by the men you know we want you
but if all men practice discipline
you if you look at japan there's a
there's a documentary for what's called
no sex please in japanese
and women pay men to just give them
cuddles sure uh yeah yeah so what's
happening now is men why because the men
don't associate themselves with women
normally they just they have like um
like
devices that they create their own
girlfriends on and they just fell in
love with this digital character
so the women actually go to like not
brothels with like the deck bars and
stuff and they pay mentors to give them
like attention is there a lot more women
to men
not sure what the ratio is but i do know
that and you know they have an upside
down population they sell more adult
nappies than they do child ones because
um there's too many old people and not
enough young people so people aren't
having sex which is creating this upside
down pyramid
um uh population same thing in singapore
singapore is trying to integrate they've
like created parks
that
like show sexual stuff to to kind of
entice people to have sex each other
yeah yeah
well they're probably having sex just
with birth control
no just like the women are saying men
don't sleep with us like the men don't
want us there's girls let you go with
nights out looking for men shut up yeah
you can't stop eventually real stuff
i just can't imagine a world like this
like i feel like there's always a guy
this is this is an example of what could
happen if women continue down the path
that they're going down uh okay this is
the ghana centric order in in in full
that you don't force don't imagine you
having to pay to get a cuddle
imagine that
you've got your youtube money coming in
the bullish a new camera
i'm trying to save for rent money for my
new new three bedroom next year we're
trying to get sign up for a membership
yeah sign up for the membership she's
trying to get the rent money but now
she's got to pay half of that money just
to get some attention from guys
this is the world that women are
creating
japan's a perfect place i think i'd just
be by myself before i paint someone but
imagine how crazy it would get like to
think that
you and your girls are so normalized
that unique girls will go out and be
like ah yeah let's go like go get
cuddles from guys that's the thing to do
oh my god that is human civilization
that is worse
tell them where to find you
listen hit me up on insta um who's
underscore eddie underscore um like i
said if you want to come on the show
have these types of discussions
present your point of view hit me up in
the dms man get on girls guys come with
your unique perspectives become more
reading well prepared because pearl
don't play
and when i'm on neither do i
stay tuned we've got more coming for you
okay guys like the video um also the
original video is in the description if
you want to check that out
like uh the video subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell and
we'll talk to you next time